this simple infinity or the absolute
notion may be called the simple essence
of life the soul of the world the
universal blood whose omnipresence is
neither disturbed or interrupted by any
difference but rather is itself every
difference and also their supersession
it pulsates within itself but does not
move inwardly vibrates yet is at rest it
is self identical for the differences
are tautological they are differences
that are this self identical essence is
therefore related only to itself to
itself implies a relationship to an
other and their relationship to self is
rather a self Sundering or in other
words that very self identical Ness is
an inner difference these sundered
moments are thus in and for themselves
each and opposite of an other thus in
each moment the other is at the same
time expressed or each is not the
opposite of another but only a pure
opposite and so each is therefore in its
own self the opposite of itself in other
words it is not an opposite at all but
is purely for itself a pure self
identical essence that has no difference
in it accordingly we do not need to ask
the question still less to think that
fretting over such a question is
philosophy or even that it is a question
philosophy cannot answer the question
that is how from this pure essence how
does difference or other Ness issue
forth from it for the division into two
moments has already taken place
difference is excluded from the self
identical and set apart from it what was
supposed to be the self identical as
thus already one of these two moments
instead of being the absolute essence
that the self identical divides itself
into two means therefore just as well
that it supersedes itself is already
divided supersedes itself as an other
nests the unity of which it is usual to
say that difference cannot issue from it
is in fact itself one of the two moments
it is the abstraction of the simplicity
or unitary nature over against the
difference but in saying that the unity
is an abstraction that is is only one of
the opposed moments it has already
implied that it is the
binding of itself for if the unity as a
negative is opposed to something than it
is a lip so positive is that which has
an antithesis within it the different
moments of self sundering and becoming
self identical are therefore likewise
only this movement assaults sol
supersession for sense the self
identical which is supposed first to
sunder itself or become its opposite is
an abstraction or is already at self a
sundered moment it's self Sundering is
therefore a super session of what is and
therefore the super session of its
divided 'no speak umming self identical
as equally as self son during what
becomes identical with itself thereby
opposes itself to itself thundering that
is if thereby puts itself on one side or
rather it becomes a sundered moment
paragraph 162 is one of those sections
in which Hegel is going to begin by
raising your hopes rather high Wow
finally gotten to the the real meat of
this he's talked a lot about the entire
inner world you know about how these
these super sensible and sensible worlds
are fused together and consciousness is
there you remember it in previous
sections we were always looking for the
absolute that which is greatest that
which is sort of unconditioned lying
behind the scenes and we've gone through
a lot of you know twos and froze finding
out well this isn't it this isn't it
this looks like it but it's not it
because you know we explore it and like
unravels and there's all these other
things going on here Hegel is going to
start up by saying this simple infinity
or the absolute notion the absolute
concept the absolute because if that's
about as good as you can get right when
you say absolute that's what Hegel is
all about isn't it and you know the
concept put them together Wow we've got
like you know plus sine plus a plus side
so he says this may be called the simple
essence of life life is this you know
vast plethora things that we can
experience we can only really experience
a sliver of them because life is itself
so fecund so fertile it takes you know
almost an infinite variety of forms for
Hegel as we've seen him talked about
earlier as we're gonna see him talk
about later on the soul of the world
that which is connecting everything
together this notion of the world's soul
is an old one and it comes from Greek
philosophy you know it's particularly
strong in the Stoics who thought that a
rationality ran through the entirety of
finite
ultimately bounded existence Hegel is
saying this absolute that that's what it
is the universal blood whose
omnipresence is neither disturbed nor
interrupted by any difference but rather
is itself everyday
as their supersession as is its
supersession this sounds pretty good
doesn't it it's it's every one of the
things and all of them bound up together
and it's not just sort of a big
pantheism of taking everything in or
some sort of monism it's even accounting
for differences and they're super
session and they're out of a bong
they're they're overcoming their
sublation however we want to translate
that word so like I said this sounds
pretty promising so what can we say
about this when he moves to talking
about this as self identical essence he
says it is self identical but for the
differences are tautological now Hagel
actually uses the cognate term tall
Telugu so here it's not just you know
Miller translating it in there he's
saying these differences are in fact
these won't recede these these
splittings these separations between
things aren't phonological what does
that mean they're saying the same thing
over and over again they're sort of
caught in a loop so he says they're
differences that are none and we've seen
this talked about quite a bit
you know differences can only be
differences that are genuine differences
when they matter in some way and the way
that they tend to matter in the Galleon
dialectic is by moving us ahead
somewhere or showing us how things are
really contrasted to each other
differences you might say become
differences that matter when they're not
merely differences in them but
opposition's or even contradictions so
he says this self identical essence is
therefore only related to itself so it
looks like they've got this you know
bounded sphere right to itself however
implies a relationship to an other and
the relation to itself is rather a self
Sundra so by the very virtue of this
absolute of this whole being what it is
this is none being a self identical
essence it already creates a
brings upon the scene all Terry you
might say as it's sort of shadow so he
says the relation to self right the
relation to itself is a self Sundering
or in other words that very self
identical this is an inter difference
so these sundered moments are thus in
and for themselves each and opposite
right and whether we think of it in
terms of this side and like you know
shooting the other out or now the other
sort of assuming it's it's priority and
you know we reflect on it and we realize
that all these self identical essence is
really the other to this we saw this
dynamic play out the forces earlier
didn't we in any case we realize that
they're each and opposite of another so
alterity other is is inescapable he says
each is not the opposite of another but
a pure opposite this is another
possibility they can exist in their
relation to each other or they can try
to separate themselves out and exist as
as pure beings extrinsic to each other
and unattached to each other pure
opposites and he says and so each is
therefore in its own self the opposite
of itself in other words it's not an
opposite at all but is purely for itself
up yourself identical essence that has
no difference in it these are all
possibilities for this absolute for this
simple infinity that is you know as
we've seen manifest within the world not
only the world of the supersensible of
what's really going on we had seen but
the world that we're experiencing either
it takes into account its other and the
fact that it is producing its other out
of itself or it ends up being less than
what it is less than what it can be so
he says accordingly we don't have to ask
the question
or even worried about the this weather
is such a question is philosophy or even
that it's a question philosophy cannot
answer he's saying something about
method here to us isn't he the question
how from this pure essence how does
difference or other nests for from it
know is Hegel saying look this just
happens you know really no explanation
for it no he's not saying that here he's
not saying ah you know you want to ask
questions about that they love sort of
like Vidkun Stein I just need to let the
fly out of the fly above it you're
asking the wrong kind of question you're
committing Israel would call it a
category mistake
Hegel's not saying that what Hagel would
actually say if he was pressed on that
is how much you read the sections all
the way leading up to this what have we
actually been developing for you what
have we been showing you the necessity
of this development why you know why it
works the way it does where it comes
from necessary says for the division of
the into two moments has already taken
place difference is excluded from the
self identical instead of performing
what was supposed to be the self
identical is thus already one of these
two moments instead of being the
absolute essence so we started out here
we have a self identical essence then we
realize that it others itself and others
itself to itself in the other which has
to be genuinely other to it and now the
self identical unity isn't really the
unity after all that we thought it was
why not because it's already divided
he says the unity of which it as usual
the same difference cannot issue from it
is in fact itself one of the two moments
so we can talk about unity in terms of
unifying two moments but then the unity
itself is something else as opposed to
either of the two moments or the both of
them together we saw this play itself
out already in you know that with the
dialectics that were involved
in cents certainty and in perception
didn't we now we're seeing it play
itself out here in a closer to the
concept manner in terms of the way the
understanding is making sense of it so
this simple infinity is really a unity
which takes into account the self
identical essence that it is and it's
other that it also is and has to be and
creates out of itself
so saying we don't want this unity to
lapse into a mere abstraction he says it
is the abstraction of the simplicity or
unitary nature over against the
difference but if we call this an
abstraction that is only one of the
opposed moments it's already implied
that it is the dividing of itself right
that is also self uttering if the unity
is a negative is opposed to something
it's a lip so by that very fact positive
is that which has an antithesis within
it here we have a key pigouvian notion
right that within unity it's not just
pure self same unity you know sort of
like a perfectly bounded sphere that
nothing else can get in it already
contains dynamism it already contains
change it already contains relation it
already contains antithesis within
itself so he says these different
moments of self sundering of becoming
self identical are likewise only this
movement of self supersession of self
authoring of self overcoming of raising
the self to a higher level since the
self identical which is supposed first
to sunder itself or become its opposite
is an abstraction or is already itself a
sundered moment it's self sundering is
therefore a super session of what what
it is and therefore the super session of
this divided 'no so it's it's is
carrying out a super session or
sublation of its own sublation it's
doing it to it to the second power you
could say so he says it's become
self identical as equally a self son
during what becomes identical with
itself thereby imposes itself to itself
sundry so we have this constant tension
going on where a thing in order to be
what it is in order to have its
determinacy even if we're talking about
the whole the absolute ask to self
sunder has to split it from itself has
to break up into more than one and then
it has to figure out how these are going
to be unified and there's there's
various possibilities here it may miss
recognize in the unity as being you know
something that has to be turned into an
abstraction as opposed to all that you
know nonsense over there
it may miss recognize the other as
something hostile is something
unimportant as something it can set
aside if it does that the dialectic is
actually going to stop at that point for
that that person and we're going to see
that's not what does happen in the play
of consciousness that we're observing
here in doing phenomenology
infinity or this absolute unrest of pure
self movement in what which whatever is
determined in one way or another for
example as being is rather the opposite
of this determinant is this no doubt has
been from the start the soul of all that
has gone before but it is in the
interval that it is first freely and
clearly shown itself appearance or the
play of forces already displays it but
it is as an explanation that it first
freely stands forth and in being finally
an object for consciousness as that
which it is consciousness is thus self
consciousness the understandings
explanation is primarily only the
description of what self consciousness
is it supersedes the differences present
to the law differences which have
already become pure differences but are
still in different and it posits them in
a single unity in force but this
unifying of them is equally and
immediately a Sundering for it
supersedes the differences and posits
the oneness of force only by creating a
new difference that of law and force
which however at the same time is no
difference and moreover from the fact
that this difference is no difference it
goes on to supersede this difference
again since it lets force B similarly
constituted to law but this movement or
necessity is thus still a necessity and
a movement of the understanding or the
movement as such is not the
understandings object on the contrary in
this movement the understanding hands as
objects positive and negative
electricity distance force of attraction
and a thousand other things which
constitute the content of the moments of
the movement the reason why explaining a
for it's so much self satisfaction is
just because in it consciousness is so
to speak communing directly with itself
enjoying only itself although it seems
to be busy with something else it is in
fact occupied only with itself
in paragraph 163 which is the third to
the end in this section of force on the
understanding Hegel is now bringing in a
new term which is going to be the the
rubric for everything that's going to
follow in the next section
self-consciousness
Szell's but with sun that is
consciousness not only of an object as
something that is other than myself the
conscious subject but also an
objectifying look at myself an
understanding of myself that turns
myself into an object for consciousness
while at the same time being what is
taking that that perspective so we're
going to see a lot of development going
on with self-consciousness here it's
just sort of raising its head but doing
so in a very important way a way that
shows us that understanding itself is
going to arrive at certain limits that
consciousness must go beyond so he says
infinity or this absolute unrest of pure
self movement in whatever is in which
whatever is determined in one way or
another that for example is beating is
rather the opposite of this determinate
Ness
this no doubt has been from the start
the soul of all that is gone before so
everything that we've been leading up to
is this infinity is an absolute unrest
this constantly dynamic process that
doesn't even you know remain dynamic in
just one direction but veers off in all
these different ways and then re
incorporates itself pure self movement
in which determinate being over and over
and over again in any way and you know
anything that is be stemmed anything
that is that is determined in one way or
another generates an opposite
determinate Ness out of that and then
the question is how is this
reincorporated how is this brought back
together and we've seen that this
happens a number of ways he now then
talks about the inner world and
appearance or the world of appearance
and we have law and force as we've seen
throughout this entire
section and sort of mediating factors
between them you know the law is if we
understand the law in terms of the inner
being of things is one thing how it
applies to all the particulars and
appearances another thing and as we go
from what is less determinate and more
abstract what is more determined that we
move from the inner world to appearance
there's a question of how we actually
reconcile all of these things
same thing with force there's this back
and forth this interplay between law and
fourth between force in its expression
force as it is in itself force as its
diffused over all the moments of force
all the things that force is supposed to
apply to force as what it is force
itself splits into two and then has to
be reincorporated as we see so it says
this no doubt has been from the start
the soul of all those go before it's in
the inner world it is first freely and
clearly shown itself why because in the
inner world we're able to analyze what
is really going on or at least what we
take to be really going on with this
world of appearances there's a certain
freedom involved and a necessity
involved in moving to the inner world
so he says appearance or the play of
forces it already displays it but it is
as explanation that it first freely
stands forth now we've seen that this
term explanation that Hangul is used
before he used in a somewhat pejorative
way and he's going to still retain some
of those resonances here you know
explanation is what the understanding
generates for itself of things it's a
way for it to talk about these things as
if it really knows them he says in being
fine being finally an object for
consciousness as that which it is
consciousness is the self consciousness
that's kind of a leap right from talking
about explanation too you know self
consciousness as taking in the object
for consciousness consciousness has been
attending to the object for
consciousness whether we understand
in terms of the appearances you know
with perception with with you know sense
certainty or these laws these forces law
itself force itself that it's trying to
make sense of consciousness has been
trying to make sense of this it's been
taking them as objects now he says in
finally beating an object for
consciousness is that which it is
consciousness
it is thus self consciousness it is
because I can say I am the one who is
giving an explanation or I want to know
what the hell is going on then I am a
self consciousness in doing so I am
treating myself both as a subject and as
an object so here's where self
consciousness is first coming on the
scene in a thematic way so he says the
the understandings explanation is
primarily only the description of what
self consciousness is why why would that
be the case isn't the understanding
supposed to be about all this stuff
outside of consciousness
well yes but as it turns out where is
all that stuff we've already seen this
this dialectic play itself out in the
earlier sections on sense certainty and
perception Hemenway what is for
consciousness also is in consciousness
this is where Hegel's idealism really
becomes important
so explanation the understandings
explanation is primarily says only the
description of what self self
consciousness is the understanding is
explaining to itself what it is that is
going on with all of this and it's
explaining to itself how it unpacks
these concepts like law and force so he
says the the understandings explanation
supersedes the differences
the law present in law differences which
have already become pure differences
positive some in a single unity and
force but this unifying of them is
equally and immediately a thundering for
it supersedes the difference and posits
the oneness of force only by creating a
new difference that between law and
force it looks like it's doing stuff
with things that are totally outside of
itself in this process doesn't it but
really what it's doing is understanding
how the understanding works in terms of
law and force that's why this is force
and the understanding because force is
not without the understanding it is
consciousness which is bringing this to
be it is consciousness which is
uncovering this dialectic this this you
know to and fro of authoring and you
know reconciliation or coming back
together of splitting into different
moments its consciousness that's taking
all this again and it's consciousness
that is representing this to itself as
what consciousness is grasping so he
goes on and he says this moment or
necessity is thus still a necessity and
movement of the understanding or the
movement as such is not the
understandings object on the contrary in
this movement the understanding has as
objects all these things like positive
and negative electricity distance force
of attraction all these things that
we've talked about over here a thousand
other things he says which constitute
the content here's where he gets us
something really interesting explanation
is the understandings way of making
sense of the world its environment its
experience what is talking about with
other people but really what explanation
is doing is coming back to the
understanding the understanding is as
Hegel's we say explaining itself to
itself it is explaining what it is that
it grants
this is why explanation he says he was
talking about something effective not
just something cognitive something
effective he says the reason why
explaining afford so much
self-satisfaction now think about that
for a second
let me pause on that we'll come back to
that that primary Clause of the sentence
isn't it fun to explain stuff I mean
what are we doing here right now I'm
actually enjoying explaining the
movements in Hegel's book to you you're
probably you know not just passively
absorbing this but taking some notes
trying to think of how you know what
would be some examples of this how does
all this apply where can we go further
with this you're engaging in the process
of explanation as well it is quite fun
it is enjoyable there's a satisfaction
involved in it
satisfaction of what as we're going to
see later on a satisfaction of desire so
the reason why explaining a for it so
much self satisfaction is just because
in it he says consciousness is communing
directly with itself we appeared to be
talking about all this stuff out here
what we're really doing is talking with
ourselves using those things as kind of
props so the primary relation is really
that of the person or the subject or
consciousness self consciousness with
itself through these things and also
through the understanding he says
consciousness is so to speak community
directly with itself enjoying only
itself although it it seems to be busy
with something else it is in fact
occupied only with itself how do i
conceptualize the world I can say that
in terms of how do I conceptualize the
war all all that stuff over there or how
do i conceptualize concepts army
the world hagel is is producing what in
language I just produced by a difference
of emphasis he's producing that sort of
shift in this section here this is
prepping us to move into the next main
section